more than 100 Trump officials former
Trump officials are now backing Ron
DeSantis for president
but if you think it matters Maga does
not care disclaimer this is a Fox news
report it appears as though they are
properly sourcing this but it is a Fox
news report an interesting detail in its
own right the headline over 100 former
Trump Administration officials back to
santis for president quote a proven
winner the officials have formed a
coalition called the eight-year Alliance
viewing DeSantis as a viable two-term
candidate exclusive Fox News has learned
that more than 100 former Trump
Administration officials have formed a
growing Coalition backing Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis to be their
nominee according to multiple sources
within the group The eight-year Alliance
says the santis is a proven winner a
contender with a depth of policy proven
by what he's done at the state level and
a leader who does what he says all of
those seem to be lies I don't think
anything there is true the primary
motivation of the group sources say is
to promote a candidate they feel would
be a viable Contender for two
presidential terms something they see in
DeSantis they also want to prevent
former president Donald Trump quote
immediately becoming a lame duck
President should he win back the White
House considering the polarizing effect
his persona has had on American politics
uh now they're using the wrong word
they're using the wrong effect it says
the polarizing affect I believe that
that is incorrect but we'll get into
grammar more today in the uh in in the
voicemail segment so uh what's
fascinating about this is that Maga
voters do not care and we've talked more
about becoming a victim of the very
monster you created that's something
we've talked about before the monster
that is Maga does not care that you know
we don't know who's in this group but oh
John Bolton doesn't like Trump anymore
William Barr doesn't think Trump is the
right person to lead the Republican
party we don't care those were losers
that Trump had to fire and then when you
say to them well why did Trump hire them
in the first place I thought he was
great at hiring oh no forget about that
forget about that so you know again we
look at the polling Trump continuing to
climb last week he breached 55 support
he continues to climb he is now Beyond
56 support we mentioned last week that
DeSantis dropped below 20 for the first
time and I don't even know how long a
very very long time this may even be
when was the San DeSantis was last below
20 in October
and DeSantis is again below 20 and by
the end of the week he may be below 19.
the Maga voters do not care about what
Republican officials who once worked for
Trump have to say they are for Trump we
are going to actually this Friday in the
Friday feedback or the feedback segment
as it may be called
um We're going to see cultists who
straight up say
I will not vote for anyone else it's
Trump or nothing that is it so uh this
is not likely to be a group of former
Trump officials that has much if any
impact on the primary just look at the
polling it is a blowout for Trump he uh
it's his to lose is where I would leave
it hey quick reminder Monday Memorial
Day there will be no show we are taking
off the federal holiday
but there will be a one-day membership
special the likes of which you have
never seen before there are not many
such examples that I can tell you uh get
on my newsletter at davidpackman.com and
then Monday morning you'll get a
beautiful email telling you how to Avail
yourself of this historic membership
discount quick break much much more
today